[Music]
on this monday night
the push for answers into that tragic
tour bus rollover
near jasper the pain for loved ones and
the unsolved questions
as the investigation gets going we were
waiting for them we saw them speeding
away
and careening off the side grief for
family and friends at the funeral for
two young sisters found dead in quebec
the shift of focus for police still
searching for the main suspect
their father the positive progress for
two
vaccine trials labeled safe and
promising
in the critical search for a covid19
cure
and the astronomical unveiling that is
out of this world
each one of those dots represents a
galaxy the new
3d map painting a much bigger and
brighter picture of the universe
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with the tragedy in the rocky
mountains
we're learning tonight who was on an ice
explorer tour bus
when it rolled over in jasper national
park three people died
24 are injured several in critical
condition
as investigators look at the final
moments leading up to the crash
heather urex west has more on the human
toll
of what should have been an
unforgettable adventure
the saskatchewan first nations community
of canoe narrow saskatchewan is in
mourning
family members tell global news 24 year
old dion de roche
was one of three people killed at
alberta's columbia ice field saturday we
were waiting for them about 150 200
meters away
to come down that hill and then we saw
them speeding away and
careening off the side and then rolling
over four or five times off the side of
the hill there
calgary's vania curtaliza witnessed the
crash with his family
they'd been scheduled to take the two
o'clock tour of the athabasca glacier
but had managed to get on an earlier bus
on standby
the vehicle remained overturned on site
at the foot of the glacier monday as
crews from the transportation safety
board
alberta occupational health and safety
and the rcmp continued their
investigation
the company that operates the bus says
it's been running tours on the glacier
without any other major incident
for nearly 40 years we average about 480
000 visitors a year
in an average year and we've been
operating these vehicles
uh since the early 80s so we've had over
16.
16 million passengers safely taken out
onto the ice
over all these years the athabasca
glacier spills out from the vast
columbia ice field
the front of the glacier called the toe
is retreating because of climate change
what's left behind looks like a
moonscape a moraine made up of rugged
debris
that can vary from large boulders to
very fine sediment and clay that can be
treacherous for travel
rcmp say two other victims include a
28-year-old woman from edmonton and a
58-year-old man from india
their names have not been released
calgary's himanshu lalaji told global
news sunday he knew
10 people including an infant who were
on the bus husband and wife
they are my friends yeah their parents
and the four months old daughter
they were all on there all on there yeah
and there is another family
from adventure husband and wife and
there is one more family
admitted husband in life lulaji has been
able to visit some of his friends in
hospital and has been told the baby is
doing okay
a tour operator says the driver of the
bus was also injured in the crash
four people remain in critical condition
in hospital heather urex west global
news calgary
it has been a very emotional day in the
town of levi quebec
two young sisters nura and homie
capentier
were laid to rest there is no one in
this line
who wants to be here but hundreds of
people showed up at this funeral home
for the visitation monday
to remember the two young lives lost
nora 11 years old
and remy just six
it's a day of sadness as this family
member it's awful
awful due to covet 19 the funeral itself
was small only close direct family was
allowed inside
a screen was set up outside for the
public the focus of the service was on
remembering
not the loss but the smiles
grief counselor julie masson worked with
the family she says the emphasis was on
the joy and love
and rami brought to everyone and
everything
senator pierre's attended the visitation
his own daughter was murdered in 2002
it was his experience and recovery that
he wanted the family to hear rebuilding
yourself
is not easy so you need people you need
other families that went through
the same kind of drama just to give them
an example that it's possible to rebuild
yourself
mike armstrong global news navy quebec
heated debate in ottawa today over
financial support for canadians in the
covid19 pandemic
while mps on both sides of the aisle
found common ground on assistance
for people with disabilities there are
still divisions over changes to the
emergency wage
subsidy abigail b minn reports
physical distancing isn't easy when
you're legally blind
just one example of an extra covet 19
challenge for people with disabilities
knowing how to navigate the lineups and
see the markers on the floor is not
something easily done when you don't
have usable vision
understanding signage on restaurant
doors coffee shop doors
elizabeth mulder says the 600 dollar
one-time payment proposed by the liberal
government is a good start
but she's unimpressed with how long it's
taking to roll out
we are 22 percent of the population in
canada
and we're a population whose voice
hasn't been hurt it's not going to cover
everyone
and that is a problem and we're going to
continue to fight
the government says it will help 1.7
million canadians but admits problems
with the system
we had to use the tax system and we had
to use the pension system
and we are and we will deliver but it's
not ideal
and it's easy to sit here and come up
with excuses or reasons but there aren't
any
so i will commit today to ensure that we
don't put our citizens in this position
again moving forward
while conservatives support the
disability aid they have issues with the
changes to the wage subsidy which is
also being debated
we've highlighted ideas to make it
simpler
you need a degree in mathematics to
fully understand all the permutations
and combinations that they've come up
with
it's a minority situation but the
liberals should have enough support to
pass the legislation
meanwhile for those living with
disabilities the weight is frustrating
and now the people that are disabled or
are
relying on extra disabilities support
the veterans and so on
they're waiting the longest and it's
ridiculous it really is ridiculous
time to time to get the bill passed
as for the wage subsidy the proposed
changes would expand the program both in
length and eligibility dropping the 30
percent decline in revenue requirement
in favor of a sliding scale pharah
abigail beeman in ottawa thank you
abigail
most of ontario has moved into phase
three of its reopening plan
restaurants and bars are allowing people
back inside
but that doesn't include toronto just
yet health officials say
that's a good thing as jeff sample
reports as communities open up
it's becoming clear that the indoor bar
scene
is uniquely suited to the spread of
covet 19.
this toronto sports bar sits in the
shadow of the blue jays stadium in the
heart of downtown
but with only the patio allowed to open
business is down
95 percent we're a sports bar without
sports like you said
and obviously tourism has been affected
greatly
by next week toronto will be one of the
only canadian cities where indoor dining
and drinks remain
off limits and experts say for good
reason
number one it's indoors number two you
have people that are in close contact
for a prolonged period of time
and at least for let's say a nightclub
you're talking more loudly
the bar scene is blamed for outbreaks
around the world
from calgary to montreal to multiple
american cities
even south korea hailed for its handling
of the pandemic
saw one bar hopper linked to a hundred
new cases
the actual numbers may be even higher
because these outbreaks are notoriously
tough to trace
if you go to a bar and are inebriated
and lose track of who you're socializing
with and suddenly i ask you
who have you been in close contact with
in the past week you're going to have a
harder time answering that question
well we do know there's a certain amount
of coveted fatigue among our young
people right now
indeed most of ontario's new confirmed
cases are under the age of 39.
i heard the same numbers as a shock but
despite his shock the premier is
allowing almost all ontario bars to open
their doors
with hot spots toronto peel and windsor
expected to follow by the end of the
month
tables must be spaced 2 meters apart and
indoor capacity limited
to 50. so be it right we have to get
this right
this sports bar is going further
collecting customers contact info
and keeping tables small he says the
greatest risk to his business now
is a second wave jeff semple global news
toronto
some disappointing news today for fans
of the professional rugby team toronto
wolf pack
the organization has announced it's
backing out of the rest of the 2020
season due to overwhelming financial
challenges
presented by the pandemic the team had
been set to resume play in england
on august 2nd authorities in france are
imposing some strict new measures to try
to curb new infections
face masks are now mandatory in all
indoor public spaces
anyone caught violating the rule faces a
fine of about 200
canadian dollars in canada the approach
to
making wearing face masks mandatory
varies from province to province
but one thing is clear where they are
compulsory that rule may stay in effect
until a vaccine is found for covid19
never before has so much effort been
concentrated
on vaccine development and tonight there
is some hopeful news
researchers in the uk the u.s and china
say
their potential vaccines are showing
promising results
but as redmond shannon reports more
research is needed to confirm their
findings
more than 150 possible covet 19 vaccines
are currently
in development a race not so much
against each other
but against the ever accelerating spread
of the virus
this university of oxford trial tested
more than 1 000 healthy adults
they were aged 18 to 55 half were given
the covet vaccine
the other half another control vaccine
the results appeared to show that the
experimental vaccine
is safe with only mild side effects
and that it provoked both types of
immune response
as expected researchers are still unsure
how strong that response needs to be
it may mean that we have to have a
really strong response against
coronavirus and we have to give
more than one dose and those have to be
large doses of the vaccine to get that
very strong response
that will be part of the next two larger
phases of the trial
where the people vaccinated are exposed
to the virus
and that needs time for those cases to
accumulate within the clinical trial
to give us confidence statistically
speaking about whether the vaccine works
there were similarly positive results
monday from a pfizer vaccine trial
and from china's cansano that company
has partnered with the canadian
government to produce its vaccine
a team at ontario's western university
is also working on a different potential
vaccine
i'm sure there will be more than one
vaccine
to be used to prevent cov19 infections
oxford researchers have stressed that
their potential vaccine still needs to
be proven to work on
older people and those with existing
health conditions
those groups will likely be at the front
of the line for any rollout
which could happen at the end of this
year at the earliest
ferrara redmond shannon in london thank
you
to another innovation in the fight
against covet 19 a group of team girls
in one of the poorest countries in the
world
have come up with a way to help those
dying from the disease
the young women aged 15 to 18 are part
of an all-female robotics team known as
the afghan dreamers
for three months they have been working
on a low-cost ventilator using old car
parts
the device which is pending approval is
partly based on a design by
mit with experts from harvard giving the
teens guidance
afghanistan has very few ventilators for
its population
regular ventilators can cost roughly
thirty thousand dollars
this one costs less than a thousand
dollars
black boxes breakthrough coming up the
big development in the tug of war for
truth
over the downing of ukraine airlines
flight 752.
months after ukrainian airliner was shot
down in iran
audio from the plane's cockpit voice
recorder has finally
been downloaded and will be analyzed in
the days ahead
all 176 people on board flight ps
752 died among them 55 canadian citizens
30 permanent residents and many others
with ties to canada
canadian officials are in paris
observing the process
but as crystal gomezing explains there
is no guarantee that we'll get access to
this long-awaited information
these images from the bureau of
investigation and analysis in paris
provide a glimpse into the decoding of
data recorders from flight
ps752 canadians are
observing the work we have two
investigators one
is the lead investigator who actually
went to tehran in january and was able
to visit the accident scene and examine
the wreckage
amateur video made public after the
disaster in january
appeared to show a plane being hit iran
later admitted the plane
was struck by surface-to-air missiles
most of the 176 people on board
had canada listed as their final
destination
the victims families want to know why
airspace over iran was
open to commercial flights while
missiles were being launched
it posted a statement saying in part we
remain
hopeful that the international bodies
and involved countries will
uncover the truth for us families but
iran is leading the investigation all of
the material retrieved
goes to them we really don't know when
or how or even
if iran will share that information with
countries like canada
the international coordination and
response group says the work on the
flight data recorders
is long overdue and it will keep
applying pressure on iran to provide
accurate and timely answers krystal
gamansen global news
london flight 752 was shot down in the
aftermath
of the u.s assassination of top iranian
general kassem suleimani
earlier today iran executed an alleged
spy
accused of passing intelligence on
soleimani's whereabouts
to the cia the u.s killed solemani in a
drone strike in baghdad back in january
iran retaliated by launching a barrage
of missiles
at an american military base in iraq
hours later
the ukrainian airlines jet was shot down
ahead the frantic rescue mission to free
a sperm whale trapped in fishing netting
off the coast of sicily
you're watching global national
[Music]
italian rescuers are scrambling to try
to free a sperm whale
tangled in illegal fishing gear the
rescue mission is happening off an
island near sicily crews have been
trying to cut their way through the
fishing net but it's extremely dangerous
the team says the animal is getting
increasingly agitated
authorities in the u.s are trying to
determine if a lawyer found dead in new
york today
is the shooter who opened fire at the
home of a federal judge
in new jersey police say the suspect
approached the family's home sunday
dressed as a fedex driver
and began shooting judge esther salas
was in the basement at the time and was
not injured
her son was killed and her husband a
defense lawyer is in critical condition
in the hospital
sales has been a federal judge since
2011. she's presided
over a few high-profile cases in recent
years including a number of
gang violence cases
up next it's out of this world the
astronomical
3d map giving earthlings the largest
ever look
at the universe
the united arab emirates has joined the
race to explore mars
the hope probe blasted off from japan
for a seven
month journey to the red planet where it
will orbit and send back data about the
atmosphere
it's expected to reach mars in february
of 2021
the year the uae celebrates 50 years
since the country's formation
there was an astronomical unveiling
today astrophysicists gave us earthlings
the
largest look at the universe ever the
new 3d map
sheds light on 11 billion years of
cosmic history
as mike drale reports it's opened up
even more questions
about what's out there we've come a long
way since the earliest astronomers began
etching their impressions of the
universe
but not as far as science fiction would
have us believe
consider this map was cutting edge only
30 years ago
those maps by comparison just to use
your analogy
really look very primitive compared to
what has just been released
he's referring to this the largest 3d
map of the universe
ever created it took 20 years of mapping
by more than a hundred of the world's
top astrophysicists
to put it all together so you're looking
at the three-dimensional positions of
galaxies
each one of those dots represents a
galaxy galaxies are wonderful things you
have disc galaxies you have elliptical
galaxies
in this map we've translated all of that
beauty and we've made a dot
and then what you're seeing is two
million dots
located in three-dimensional space we're
in the middle
but perspective is everything so
consider the distance from the earth to
the sun
and this map is a million billion times
larger
and it's getting bigger because of a
mysterious force called dark energy
which nobody truly understands it's a
theoretical
einstein level stuff rest assured most
of us who don't get
into the nitty-gritty of theoretical
cosmology
also you know get headaches when we
listen to some of these seminars
the earliest maps used a simple science
to show the outer edges of what we knew
existed sea monsters so we've come a
long way
with high-tech telescopes and a better
understanding of the origins of the
universe
imagine where we'll be a century from
now mike drolet global news toronto
that's global national for this monday
from back here on earth i'm farah nasser
tonight's your canada is steep rock
manitoba does your community have a
unique landmark you'd like to share with
us
email your pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks so much for watching donna
friesen will be back here tomorrow
until next time take care of yourselves
and each other
good night
you